I know what people will say they'll say
look it's not possible we won't have a
chance of shifting the great Memorial
edifice of the European Commission I
really really don't believe that is true
the notional purpose of the backstop is
to prevent a hard border in Northern
Ireland and no one in Dublin or London
or Brussels wants a hard border intends
a hard border or thinks a hard border is
remotely necessary so we must have the
courage to ask and we must mean it this
time
all this vacuous talk of extending
article 50 is only is dishonest but of
course it's also weakening our
negotiating position once again to
extend article 50 now would do nothing
but erode trust in politics and if we
get it right now and we have some
courage we can forestall all the years
of wrangling and uncertainty that I'm
afraid will be the legacy of agreeing
this deal and we can stop going on
miserably about the whole process of
brexit which I think people have had
enough of and start talking about what
brexit can do for the people of this
country and bring this country together
I'm a believer in in the benefits of
migration by the way I think it enriches
our country it brings talent and it's a
tribute to Britain that people want to
come here but I think there's got to be
a balance and if an influx of labour is
being used not only to prevent an
investment in capital equipment but also
in skills and in the prospects of young
people then we need to think carefully
about how we control immigration you
look at who wrote in what where it's
clear that people felt the gap in that
in their prospects and their attainments
between London and the region they
wanted something done about it they
wanted attention to be paid and one
thing you can do to help is to devolve
fiscal power to cities big cities and
the regions and that should be our cap
our campaign take those local taxes
bundle them together and give them to
mayors and politicians to
spend on their local priorities so that
they then have themselves an incentive
to go for policies that deliver growth
and opportunities quite high enough no
increases in taxes and no one rich or
poor to pay more than 50 percent of
their income in taxes that's not because
we want to create a tax haven for the
rich but because we want to stimulate
the income we need to pay for this
national program of cohesion
I'm not a nationalist if by that you
mean I'm a xenophobe or someone who
deprecates other countries and cultures
absolutely not far from it I will Boris
probably else but I do believe that the
idea of belonging to a nation or group
can be immensely powerful and positive
to maximize the opportunities ahead of
us we need that autonomy and we need
that freedom and to achieve that
creative autonomy we must follow the
logic of what parliament has voted for I
confidently prophesied unlike many of
the gloomy predictions that you are
hearing at the moment I though I tell
you that the people of this country will
prosper and they will manage that change
there will still be Mars bars made in
this country there weren't that there
will be no shortage of Mars bars we will
still have potable drinking water in
Britain there as far up the engines stop
dithering emulate the spirit of JCB and
removed from our path the backstop that
is the last brussels built blockage
20:13 you described yourself as the most
pro-immigration politician in degree I
think I said roughly I think I said
roughly the same does not suggest 80
million just to win an election well
actually I didn't say anything about
about Turkey in the in the record I
didn't say anything about I didn't well
you know I didn't say a thing about
taking it and and I think anybody who's
followed my utterance is over the last
20 years will know that I am always been
in the camp of those who defends and
supports depends and since I made no
remarks I can't this I can't decide that
I didn't make any remarks about
immigration can be a wonderful thing for
our country but as I said time and time
again
it's got to be controlled I mean fair
question I think I try to answer it in
my in my speech actually this is the
moment and I don't think we've gone in
with sufficient drive and JCB style
gumption to get this this you would know
come on I tried for about a year
everybody yeah we're know absolutely
this is all internal political which I
did try very very hard Beth mr. Johnson
we're in a moment of national crisis and
here you are in front of a digger making
a naked leadership pitch Theresa May has
won a confidence vote why don't you just
get behind her and stop under my
well actually what I'm offering is
you're quite right that the Prime
Minister there's one the confident
that's terrific alive ated I voted for
her of course but she's a bit cheap but
but she has not succeeded emphatically
not succeeded in getting her deal
through Parliament and as I as I said
just now it's gone down by two hundred
and a majority of two hundred and thirty
that's unprecedented it cannot come back
it is a it is an ex deal what is needed
now and that's what I'm trying to do is
humbly and sincerely offer a way forward
we need to get through this and we can
only do it if we have conviction and
determination and we follow the logic of
what brexit was all about and it's
actually a massive opportunity she needs
to go back to Brussels and remove the
backstop or the most pernicious elements
of the backstop of the way it locks us
in from the deal and if she can do that
and if she really ins it this time then
we can make progress
III think that most people in this
country feel that they've had quite
enough elections and I certainly do what
they what they voted for was to leave
the European Union and to take advantage
of the opportunities of brexit that's
what we should all be getting on in the
fence supporting so yes I think I think
it's highly unlikely that that will be
the outcome I think it would be the rub
I mean I think a snap election is not
the way what right way through why call
a snap election when you can just go
back to to Brussels and and and make the
point that this deal is unacceptable we
want a better one and it's so
overwhelmingly in their interests to do
better and and they can